I have ESPN's undefeated here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you mark man I'm
in LA right now man I got time for
Roscoe's today but it's a beautiful day
in LA it is that what is the number one
story going into this all-star game Marc
Spears
LeBron LA Paul George LA the fact that
it's in LA with these two guys making
such a major decision and you know I'm
sure there's gonna be a lot of questions
to them about possibly playing for the
Lakers and the Clippers fans short
Clippers as well but I think to me that
that's a bigger story line in LA sir and
being in LA makes it even stronger well
let's let's dive into that a little bit
more mark because I heard your you know
your comment about the Clippers we hear
that a lot too not just living in Los
Angeles but a lot that that there's no
chance that LeBron will come to the
Clippers why why not and I'm and by that
I want to back that up with this theory
here okay you go to the Lakers now
you're just doing what Kobe and magic
and Shaq you're just going down the list
of everybody Chamberlain just go down a
list of what everybody there has done
you do it for the Clippers and you're
the first you create your own world
there and you're doing it with Jerry
West now as opposed to what Jerry West
had built in the past and maybe you can
get you know all the max contracts for
Doc Rivers and there's no Lavar ball
saying you got to sign all the
ballplayers mark why not well I think
the Clippers are really like a year away
from even having the money where they
could get another guy to come with him
so I think the timing is part of it
the Lakers now with their moves have
none of the money to go do it oh man but
you know man you know how it is man this
is and this isn't a diss on the Clippers
because I have nothing against them and
I definitely hear what you're saying but
you know people are in love with that
Lakers mystique people are in love with
you know that Jersey the the history
you know saying we'll play their magic
played there and Kobe played there you
know you know there's just a coolness
that comes with saying I play for the
Lakers that never really translates the
same with the Clippers and the city of
Los Angeles is you know shows that
there's a different vibe at a Lakers
game and a Clippers game most of
celebrities gravitate towards the Lakers
the city no matter what the Clippers do
their people are going to pay attention
to the Lakers more so for a guy like
LeBron if he were to come who is
certainly gotten his foot ingrained in
the film industry certainly he could go
either way and it'll be okay but I just
think it's it's that coolness factor
that the LA Lakers give that nobody else
can give well Marc we had maverick
Carter here in this seat directly to the
right of my desk just a few months ago
where he said that doesn't matter bran
can make movies and star in movies from
wherever and I'm sure Cavs fans are here
in that saying okay how about him
staying here so what what about LeBrons
future might not be los angeles-based
best you can tell well you know I was
there on Sunday in Boston um you know
when uh Cavaliers the new-look Cavaliers
played for the first time and he looked
fun they were talented they were great
they fit LeBron better
I think the Cavs that basically put
themselves in a position now where
you're gonna make it really tough for
LeBron to make a decision because this
team is good enough to go to the finals
and then also keep in mind they got
their number one pick from a Nets team
that's lost a lot what are they lost
like seven or eight in a row so I mean
you're talking about possibly having
this team with the number one pick in
the draft for a top five pick I think
it's gonna be a really really hard
decision for LeBron to depart from them
and if you're a Cleveland fan or hear
their general manager without a Kobe
Altman has done a fantastic job you
can't be ashamed of the team that you
put together for him to make a decision
on you you can't blame the team because
they gave him something
very good to play with Marc Spears from
ESPN's undefeated here on the Rich Eisen
show level of concern for Warriors fans
not being in first place by the all-star
break with a rockets team that has won
10 in a row with some dynamic players
all-time great and James Harden on it
would be what now concern for the West
our concern for the CE o I'd go with the
West with the West oh I think they
certainly should be concerned the
Rockets are really strong and they made
some good additions with with Joe
Johnson and Brandan Wright but I still
don't see anybody beating them four
times I know they haven't played that
great I'm late they're ready to be on
the beach they're ready to have a mai
tai they're ready to do nothing they
needed to get away from each other I
think they'll be fine it will certainly
be a big boost for Houston to have home
court advantage they they certainly get
a boost plane at home but I still like
the Warriors making it to the finals and
it's just not gonna be easy anymore do
you have a problem with what Steve Kerr
did letting the guys on the team run the
huddle against a team that you know what
both ways man cuz like I I'm around
Steve enough living in Oakland that I I
know there's a method to his madness you
know that that he's trying to figure out
a way to reengage these guys before
all-star break comes the sad thing is
you know it's like you're putting salt
in the team's womb I mean the Suns are
bleeding and bleeding bad so to do it
against them you know I'm sure it felt
very disrespectful to them and then they
got drilled in the process so you know
Jared Dudley said in this tweet what
they do this against the Spurs what they
do this against another elite team
that's a good question so I kind
understood but I don't think Steve meant
any disrespect but I could certainly
understand why the suns didn't like it
there any history you know we know he
has a history with the sun's is there
any history in that respect between him
and sons you know I hadn't thought about
that part
that's a good question you know maybe
maybe when the season's over I'll uh
I'll have to move a glass of wine or
something you look the vault dig into
that mark Spears a couple more minutes
left with more experienced and show what
what when does this meeting between the
players and the refs and everybody go
down this weekend walk me through the
waiting room and all that stuff as you
can tell well I'm actually about to meet
with Michele Roberts and the meetings
over this weekend I mean what does it do
I don't know what it does and the
problem is if you look at the referees
which how long you been watching the NBA
the professional since I started I guess
it's SportsCenter in 96 how many of the
referees do you recognize now zero zero
there's the issue that nobody talks
about all these guys are new we when we
began our career it was javi
it was the Crawford it was the feta it
was Jimmy Clark it was Hugh like we knew
all the guys we knew their personalities
now everybody's brand new so the it's
like you know having a league full of
rookies you know a bunch of guys with
and a lady that that are just trying to
cut their teeth and get into
experimenting a veteran restaurant you
know and there's just been this great
turnover of referees as these guys have
gotten older so I think there's nothing
that could really change anything I
guess you could ask the players to be
more polite but there's gonna be some
growing pains with these new referees
that we're just gonna have to be ready
for until they get more experienced but
didn't weren't we going through a period
just a couple years ago like that man
all of these refs I mean we're not
paying to see them we're not paying to
see Joey Crawford you know that that's
not what we're doing here you know
didn't we go through all that though so
I mean better and Joey had their
personalities and that that you know
we're certainly unique to the game
I didn't think most of the referees were
like that but those guys had like
20 years of experience I don't I would
gather that most of referees have less
than five now so um like I said man is
we're just gonna have to grin and bear
it and also to the referees credit
they're in a situation now it's tough
because you got the two-minute reports
you got people replaying things and
super slow-motion like the game is not
played that way they're under so much
more scrutiny than ever before it's not
an easy job which also is called some of
the referees to leave because a few of
them went to the college level so I'd be
curious to see how many referees that
were rough at ten years ago are still
roughing now hmm so who's gonna be in
the room best you can tell for this car
veteran referees in the referee union
leader Michelle Roberts some of the
players I probably know a little bit
more after I talk to her as far as exact
like Chris Paul would Chris Paul be in
there I mean he'd have to be there right
you know but he's to blame a little bit
right well they should send dream on in
there and they should send Durant in
there and see if they eject them from
the meeting - right team up in the
all-star practice and meet with all
those guys afterwards because those are
the main guys know causing a stir I know
we're joking about it but why not right
I mean that's the point they make it
enough to say anything but you're
basically saying it doesn't matter
anyway these just the the refs have to
just keep on keeping on and they're and
the players have to just get to know
each other you know I mean from what
you're telling me no I mean I just I
just think that the growing pains until
they get more experienced is going to
continue and you know there's also an
emotion to the game and in endo a word
of blame - you know social media we
could we could magnify things and make
them bigger than they seem - but um you
know I think the best conversation is
probably with the stars and not just
what around about group of folk speaking
of social media at mark with a CJ Spears
ESPN is how you
can follow mark spears thanks for the
time enjoy your time here and now maybe
I'll see it over the weekend at Staples
they'll be great you got it it's a mark
Spears the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience